foreign
[Music]
the agenda is adopted
come for me
of the council's provisions
in this meeting
it is so decided
foreign
Mariano
thank you Mr President
I thank you
members of the council
allowing me the opportunity today to
update you on the iaea activities
concerning the safety security and
safeguards in Ukraine
your own personal conviction in
supporting me and the work of the iea
has been remarkable thank you very much
Mr President I also thank the council
for their continuing support for the
iaea's efforts I will also lay out the
basic principles needed to prevent a
nuclear accident
as you may remember I have addressed the
Council on the situation in Ukraine four
times before on for March 11 August 6th
September
and 20 27 October last year
however I see today's meeting as the
most important one and I will explain
why
first
I want to briefly update you on what the
agency has been doing in Ukraine
it is now over 15 months since the
beginning of the war May remind you that
this is the first time in history that a
war is being fought amid the facilities
of a major nuclear power
program
this includes several of Ukraine's five
nuclear power plants and other
facilities have come under direct
shelling and all npps have lost off-site
power at some point
furthermore
one of Ukraine's nuclear power plant
saporizia NPP has come under Russian
military and operational control
the iea has been closely monitoring the
situation and assisting Ukraine every
single day since the start of the war
these assistance has involved The
Continuous engagement of the iaea's
incident and Emergency Center
there have been 12 expert missions to
Ukraine I have personally LED seven of
them including two to the znpp
additionally since first September 2022
we have had an iaea support and
assistance Mission Station at saporizia
NPP which is literally on the front
lines of this war and we have and we are
on the eighth rotation of our dedicated
and courageous staff
who have had to cross that front line
to undertake this vital work many times
23 of our staff have been part of these
teams and since January this year we
have had other dedicated
iaea expert
stationed missions stationed at every
other major Ukrainian nuclear site
Nuclear Power Plant South Ukraine
nuclear power plant nitsky nuclear power
plant and the Chernobyl nuclear power
plant their presence allowing us to
provide the International Community with
reliable information on the Safety and
Security situation at each one of those
sites as well
another 58 of our staff have been part
of these teams totally more than 2 350
person days all of our staff in Ukraine
and I wish to take the opportunity to
thank the United Nations Secretary
General and the under secretaries for
Safety and Security and Operational
Support once again for their help in
making this happen
moreover we have facilitated an
international assistant package totaling
more than 5 million euros with 17
deliveries of vital equipment to Ukraine
and I think member states for their
contribution in this regard
we are putting in place a comprehensive
program of Health Care Assistance
including through equipment and
psychological support for all Ukrainian
nuclear workers
in addition to our work on nuclear
Safety and Security we are also
continuing our Vital safeguards
verification activities across Ukraine
ensuring that there is no diversion of
nuclear material for military purposes
and we are keeping the world informed of
the situation that Ukraine nuclear cites
in more than 160 web statements updates
reports and briefings including to the
United Nations General Assembly and to
your distinguished selves here at the
security Council
the president
the nuclear Safety and Security
situation at this operation nuclear
power plant in particular continues to
be extremely fragile and dangerous
military activities continue in the
region and may well increase very
considerably in the near future
the plant has been operating on
significantly reduced staff which
despite being in temporarily shut down
is not sustainable
and there have been seven occasions
when the site lost all of side power and
had to rely on emergency on emergency
diesel generators which is as you know
the last line of defense against the
nuclear accident to provide essential
cooling of the reactor and spend fuel
the last one the seventh occurred just
one week ago
we are fortunate that a nuclear accident
has not yet happened as I said at the
iaea Board of Governors
last March we are rolling a dice
and if this continues then once they our
luck will run out
so we must
all do everything in our power to
minimize the chance that it does
as the council knows since returning
from my first of two missions to the
saboration nuclear power plant last
September I have been urging all parties
to protect the nuclear Safety and
Security of the plant
these has involved numerous meetings
intensive consultations and exchanges
including at the highest levels in
Ukraine and the Russian Federation
Mr President
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
as you would recall already a year ago I
have elaborated the seven indispensable
pillars for ensuring nuclear Safety and
Security during an armed conflict these
are number one
the physical Integrity of facilities
whether it is the reactors the fuel
ponds or radioactive waste stores must
be maintained two all Safety and
Security Systems and equipment must be
fully functional at all times
three the operating staff must be able
to fulfill their Safety and Security
duties and have the capacity to make
decisions free of undue pressure
four there must be a secure off-site
power supply from the Greed for all
nuclear sites five there must be
uninterrupted logistical Supply chains
and transportation to and from the sites
six they must be effective on-site and
off-site radiation monitoring systems
and emergency preparedness and response
measures and seven the there must be
reliable communication with the
regulator and others
this Common Sense rules derived from a
vast body of iea documents guidelines
and experience they have been
universally quoted and supported and
this is very encouraging
a nuclear or radiological accident
during the ongoing conflict could have
disastrous consequences for the people
of Ukraine
for the people of Russia as well as
neighboring states
and Beyond
the time has come to be more specific as
to what is required
we must prevent a dangerous release of
radioactive material
to that end and mindful of the seven
dispensable pillars that I just quoted
I have been working intensively and in
consultation with the leadership of
Ukraine and the Russian Federation
as a result of this intensive
consultations I have identified
the following concrete principles to
help ensure nuclear Safety and Security
at zndp in order to prevent nuclear
accident and ensure the Integrity of the
plant I see these commitments as
essential to avoid the danger of a
catastrophic incident
number one
there should be no attack of any kind
from or against the plant in particular
targeting the reactors spend fuel
storage other critical infrastructure or
personnel
number two
znpp should not be used as storage or a
base for heavy weapons
for example
multiple rocket launchers artillery
systems and Munitions and tanks
or military personnel that could be used
for an attack from the plant
three
off-site power to the plant should not
be put at risk to that effect all
efforts should be made to ensure that
off-site power remains available and
secure at all times
four
all structures
systems and components essential to the
safe and secure operation of the plant
should be protected from attacks or acts
of sabotage
five no action should be taken that
undermines
these principles
the iaea experts on-site namely the iaea
support and assistance mission to
support
items
will report to the iea director General
on the observance of these principles
the director General will report
publicly on any violation of these
principles
the president
I respectfully and solemnly ask both
sides to observe these principles
I request
distinguished members of the security
Council
to unambiguously support
them
let me say something very clearly this
principles are to no one's detriment
and to everyone's benefit
avoiding a nuclear accident is the
president
is possible
abiding by the iaea's five principle is
the way to start
it's a president distinguished
colleagues the IAA five principles to
avoid a nuclear accident are hereby
established the iea intends to start
monitoring these principles through its
own site mission
I thank you very much for your attention
Mr President
[Music]
for his presence
Ministry of Foreign Affairs of the Swiss
Confederation
civilian nuclear facilities in Ukraine
Las Vegas
in this Council it's positioned on the
Russian military operation against
Ukraine we'll reiterate our call on the
Russian Federation
any attack perpetrated against civilian
infrastructure
for Switzerland respect for
international law in general
International humanitarian law in
particular foreign
[Music]
nuclear safety in all armed
we have the opportunity
pillars in this particular case
five principles
to ensure the protection of the civilian
population
and fully supports these proposals
here is a pragmatic and targeted
approach
I'm convinced that this is an important
contribution in this crisis situation
proposed by the agency
respect for international humanitarian
law is a priority of Swiss foreign
notably in occupied territories
the danger around the nuclear power
plant remains
foreign
representative of Ecuador
so your minutes
the work
and the role of this organization
access and presence without any
impediments or limitations
be guaranteed
foreign
and to prevent any possible actions
and Safeguard offered by the npt over
the peaceful use
prevented from adopting final
recommendations
foreign
and to alleviate tensions
the largest nuclear plant of Europa of
Europe thank you
representative of France
foreign
it must be returned
to Ukraine and Russia must stop with its
troops and stop playing
thank you says
Mr President
of the Ia Raphael Grossi for his
briefing
and remains an unquestionable priority
for our country
from the very beginning
zelinski regime and its Western backers
foreign
with the measures that we've already
been implementing for a long time in
accordance with decisions taken at the
national level
no attacks were ever carried out from
the territory of the Zacks
has never seen any heavy weapons
territory nor is there any military
personnel present at the power plants
that could be used to carry out an
attack
specific steps to protect the most
sensitive installations systems and
components of the plant from any attacks
or sabotage
in the current conditions to
strengthen the Safety and Security of
the power plant in accordance to their
National legislation and our obligations
under relevant internet National legal
instruments to which our country is a
party
foreign
to any attacks by Ukraine against the
nuclear power plant its critical
infrastructure including its power lines
as well as the city of energy which is
home to the Personnel of the power plant
and their families
Secretariat will also demonstrate
against the partiality of lack of bias
and openly condemn Ukraine's actions
which have repeatedly brought the world
catastrophe which could impact not only
the territories around the new but far
beyond including in Europe
and that would be a nuclear disaster
thank you
universe
[Music]
Mr President we are delighted to see you
back in New York for the final stretch
of a very successful first ever
presidency of the security Council by
your country
I thank Mr Rafael Grossi
director general of the international
atomic energy Agency for his important
briefing
acknowledge the presence of the
permanent representative of the Ukraine
in this meeting
Mr President the bulletin of the atomic
scientists
said this year it's Doomsday Clock at
night second to midnight
this is the closest to midnight the
clock has ever been since it was
established in 1947 to illustrate the
global
existential threat as the dawn of the
nuclear weapons age
this sense of urgency was equaled by the
iaea in its publication called nuclear
safety security and safeguards
Ukraine from
February 2022 to February 2023 which is
stated and I quote
since the start of the armed conflict
the events that have Arisen have either
partially or fully compromised the iaeas
seven indispensable pillars for ensuring
nuclear safety
and security during an armed conflict
for almost all nuclear facilities and
Main activities involving radioactive
sources in Ukraine and of course
Mr President this conflict reminds the
world of a potential that the escalation
of the conflict in nuclear conflagration
either by accident intention or
miscalculation is a real possibility
the conflict has already put nuclear
reactor sites in Chernobyl and in
zaporizia in the midst of a war zone
risking the widespread the release of
radioactive materials
to add to the to the sense of urgency
nuclear Doctrine
portions are being revived and
non-proliferation Agreements are
suspended
while deterrence theory has
traditionally dominated nuclear
doctrines we are witnessing
shifts towards doctrines emphasizing
limited use of tactical nuclear weapons
as possible deterrence response to the
use of similar weapons by an adversary
these changes increase the risk of
misunderstandings miscalculations
and unintended escalation all of which
undermine our effort towards a nuclear
safe World Mr President
Mozambique supports any measure aiming
at protecting and preventing and nuclear
incident or accident including those
portrayed by the I
aea's director General
the iaea as we heard emphasize the
importance of estranged globally
coordinate approach to nuclear safety
an African perspective on this issue
advocates for enforced Collective
responsibilities
in which a nuclear threat anywhere is a
threat to all Humanity as stated in our
building treaty therefore it's our
Collective responsibility to avoid a
scenario of a repeat of a nuclear
incident or accident in Ukraine
Andy in an already fragile geopolitical
contest Mr President in conclusion we
must commit to a Cooperative Global
effort to enhance nuclear Safety and
Security in Ukraine and indeed the world
we must hit the iaea's advice and
support the talks for an agreement on
the Urgent establishment to offer
nuclear Safety and Security protection
zones as we repeatedly stated
ending the conflict is the most viable
and sustainable solution to ensure
nuclear Safety and Security
leading to Safe lives and indeed
Humanity
this conflict has gone too far and has
brought us to this febrile and
dangerously
destabilizing place of eminent nuclear
confrontation
in this regard we reiterate our call for
the immediate cessation of hostilities
and return to direct negotiation between
the parties as a matter of urgent action
by the security Council I thank you
[Music]
thank you Mr President and thank you
director General grocer for briefing the
Council on this pressing issue and I'd
like to welcome the permanent
representative of Ukraine to this
meeting
the United States appreciates the focus
in leadership the iaea has demonstrated
in its efforts to help prevent a nuclear
Calamity in Ukraine particularly at the
zaporizia nuclear power plant
I also extend my heartfelt thanks to the
iaea and Ukrainian staff at saparesia
who have labored under unimaginable
pressure to prevent a catastrophic
incident
director General Grossi we appreciate
the concrete principles you have
presented to us today we urge everyone
in this room to support these important
principles just as we urge everyone in
this room to support all efforts to
avoid a nuclear incident at zapparesia
an incident that could catastrophically
impact both Ukraine and the surrounding
region principles laid out today should
foster an ongoing discussion about the
steps we must we must take to ensure
nuclear Safety and Security at zaporizia
I'll also note that these principles
build on the seven indispensable pillars
of nuclear Safety and Security which the
director General introduced last spring
but colleagues we know that one country
a permanent member of this Council
continues to demonstrate its flagrant
disregard for these principles since
March of last year when Russia illegally
seized the zaparesia plant the
International Community has held its
breath each time the facility has been
hit by shells each time it is lost
external power
each time Russian forces have detained
essential staff
an imagery released in April by the
United Kingdom which showed Russian
military and placements atop reactors at
the plant only exacerbated our concerns
about the facilities nuclear safety
to make matters worse recent news
reports indicate that Moscow has
disconnected
zepparisia's vital radiation monitoring
sensors which means the plant's data is
now being sent to the Russian nuclear
regulator
this is a clear escalation of Russia's
efforts to undermine Ukrainian
sovereignty and authority over the
zaporizia plant
and this undermines our ability to have
confidence in the level of nuclear
safety at the plant
let me be clear the zaparesia nuclear
power plant belongs to Ukraine and its
data must go to Ukraine not to Russia
Russia's Reckless actions stand in stark
contrast to Ukraine's responsible
behavior
throughout this conflict director
General agrossi has made clear that
Ukraine has fully cooperated in
implementing safeguards at all its
nuclear facilities and that the iaea has
not found any indication of a
proliferation concern in Ukraine the
iaea's independent assessments have been
essential to verifying the lack of
diversion of nuclear material in Ukraine
and the presence of the agency's
technical experts has helped support the
safe and secure operation at all of
Ukraine's nuclear power plants
colleagues those of us who sit on this
Council are entrusted with a sacred
responsibility to maintain International
Peace and security
and there's no doubt that Russia's
actions are an attack on the Safety and
Security of the region and the world and
we must stand together and demand
President Putin in this this madness if
Russia wants to show that it is serious
about reducing nuclear risk at zaporizia
it can take steps to remove its weapons
and civil military personnel from the
plant maintain an uninterrupted power
supply to the plant from the territory
under Ukraine's control provide a
humanitarian Corridor to rotate
Ukrainian Personnel at the plant to
reconnect the plant's radiation
monitoring systems and return full
control of the of the plant to the
competent Ukrainian authorities
and if Russia wants to show that it is
serious about reducing nuclear risk more
broadly is it must stop as irresponsible
nuclear rhetoric and stop undermining
undermining the arms control regime the
United States is also deep concerned
about Russia's stated intent to deploy
nuclear weapons in Belarus we all should
be it is entirely entirely within
moscow's control to avert a nuclear
catastrophe into end this war of
aggression against Ukraine a war that
has caused so much pain destruction and
death the United States will continue to
stand with the Ukrainian people and
support Ukraine for as long as it takes
thank you Mr President
foreign
thank you sir
for the information that he just shared
with the council information
points to a volatile situation around
the nuclear
[Music]
to contain a situation
foreign
the tendency towards trivialization
[Music]
thank you president
and I thank director General grocery for
your briefing
since the start of its full-scale
invasion
Russia's Reckless actions at nuclear
facilities across Ukraine have
threatened the safety of ukrainians and
the International Community
let me be clear
Russia's control of zaparesia nuclear
power plant is illegal and continues to
pose a serious threat
to the facilities safe and secure
functioning
the iaea's February report
confirmed the presence the continued
presence of military personnel and
activity across the site
and described a situation that is I
quote
dangerous precarious and challenging
unauthorized military vehicles and
stalls sit in turbine Halls
landmines in the vicinity of the plant
in danger Ukrainian operating staff and
delay maintenance work
Supply chains and Associated Logistics
continue to be severely impacted by the
conflict
an off-site power supplies remain
vulnerable
new imagery
shows Russian forces have established
sandbag fighting positions on the roofs
of several of the six reactor buildings
this indicates that they have integrated
the actual reactor buildings
of Europe's largest nuclear power plant
into tactical defense planning
Russia's actions have violated all of
director General grassi's Seven Pillars
of nuclear Safety and Security
we've always been clear that as long as
Russia's illegal control of the plant
continues
it's safe and secure operation cannot be
insured
as the Director General said
the situation simply cannot go on
I thank him and his colleagues at the
iaea
for their bravery and for their
ceaseless efforts to support nuclear
Safety and Security in Ukraine together
with the Ukrainian government
we continue to support the iaea's work
in Ukraine
and its efforts to ensure the safe and
secure use of nuclear technology around
the world
we recognize director General grassi's
efforts to maintain safety at the
zaparesia plant including through his
five principles
as part of a solution that respects
Ukraine's sovereignty
I pay tribute to
to The Bravery professionalism and
resilience of Ukrainian staff at the
plant who continue to work tirelessly
under duress
president
the situation at zaparisia is entirely
of Russia's making
Russia can resolve this situation at any
time
it should withdraw its troops from the
plant
and from all of Ukraine
I thank you
representative
of the United States
of Japan
thank you Mr President
allow me to begin my statement by
expressing our sincere appreciation to
director General grocery for his
insightful briefing on the latest
developments on the ground
we reaffirm support for the seven
indispensable pillars of nuclear safety
and nuclear security and highlight the
importance of ensuring and promoting the
Safety and Security of nuclear
facilities under any circumstances
Mr President
we once again express our greatest
concern over Russia's grossly
irresponsible seizure and militarization
of the zap original nuclear power plant
this poses a serious threat to the
nuclear Safety and Security of not only
Ukraine but also Europe and the entire
world
as the Director General said just now
the situation of the znpp and its
Ukrainian operating staff remains
dangerous and precarious with a Seven
Pillars outlined by the director General
being compromised constantly
we condemn it in the strongest terms
Russia's manifest violation of the U.N
Charter and its aggression against
Ukraine as well as Russia's continued
control over the znpp
Japan strongly urges the Russian
Federation to immediately withdraw its
forces and Personnel from the znpp
we also condemn that signing by the
defense Ministers of Russian Belarus of
an agreement establishing procedures for
the deployment of Russian tactical
nuclear weapons in Belarus which further
increases attention while Russia
continues its aggression against Ukraine
Japan can never accept Russia's nuclear
threat let alone its use of nuclear
weapons under any circumstances
other member states should also refrain
from supporting such actions either
directly or in directory
Mr President
Japan reiterates its deep appreciation
to director General Grocery and the
Secretariat and continues to support
their efforts to strengthen nuclear
Safety and Security off and the
appreciation of safeguards to nuclear
material and facilities in Ukraine We
Salute The Continuous presence of iaea
experts and their focus on ensuring
nuclear Safety and Security at the site
during this very difficult time
in this regard we also commend the
ongoing work by director General to
protect the nuclear Safety and Security
of the nuclear facilities
in particular
the role of the isams is essential for
acquiring first-hand objective and
impartial observation about the
situation regarding the let NPP
Japan has provided a financial
contribution for the Secretariat to
facilitate missions including support
for the procurement of special vehicle
for the provide for the periodic
rotation system of iaea Staff bringing
our total contribution for the iaea's
activities to approximately 12 million
euros
Mr President Japan continues to support
DG grossi's efforts in a manner that
respects Ukrainian sovereignty over its
internationally recognized territory I
thank you
representation
president thank you Mr President I thank
the director General grocer for his
presentation and his new proposal
Albania appreciates the professionalism
objectivity and impartiality of the iaea
and considers the role of the agency
essential for the non-proliferation
regime
we support its continued efforts to
secure the protection of these operation
nuclear plant in Ukraine
colleagues
since Russia invaded Ukraine and
occupied zaporiza we have asked some
very basic yet fundamental questions
under which rights and rules has Russia
occupied and taken ownership of a key
piece of the power generation
infrastructure of another country
under which logic has Russia militarized
the biggest nuclear power plant in
Europe
these like other questions related to
the war of choice in Ukraine remain
unanswered to date
save the propaganda and the distorted
narrative aimed for domestic use
we know that since its occupation the
normal activity of the facility has been
severely disrupted and in no less than
seven cases it has lost all external
power for several hours creating an
extremely precarious nuclear Safety and
Security situation for a major disaster
professionals have long warned that
on-site diesel generators cannot cool
each of the six reactors in the long
term
and for as long as the current situation
continues the risk of major escalation
is real a clear and present danger
Albania strongly condemns the illegal
seizure of the Ukrainian nuclear power
plants by Russia and its militarization
the intentional weaponization of a
nuclear plant is wrong and dangerous
because there is no other case in
history no other one when a nuclear
plant has been used as a shield to
protect military troops and Hardware as
Russia is doing
this abstract and dangerous situation
cries the need for Urgent International
regulation governing nuclear power
plants in our time and we hope the IAA
will tackle the issue
in the meantime we call on Russia to
implement without delay the resolutions
of the iaea Board of Governors so that
the competent Ukrainian authorities
regain full control of all nuclear
facilities located within International
recognized borders of Ukraine including
the separation Nuclear Power Plant
Ukrainian Personnel operating in the
plant and the Russian occupation must be
able to perform their important duties
without restrictions threats or pressure
and the supply networks must be restored
to ensure the stability of the plant's
six reactors
Mr President
as stated earlier by DG Grossi the
general situation in the area in the
area near the separija remains
unpredictable and potentially dangerous
undermining these seven essential
pillars of nuclear Safety and Security
as defined by the iaea
it is therefore imperative to protect
the plant to prevent the risk of a
serious nuclear accident with
catastrophic consequences for the
population and the environment
the proposals presented today by Digi
grocery could be a good basis to ensure
the protection and safe children clear
facilities in Ukraine and specifically
these upper Asia power plant and we have
full confidence in the iaea in
facilitating its implementation
but the rules of the problem with remain
unresolved until Russia withdraws its
troops from Ukraine's to gear facilities
and transfers the control to the
legitimate Ukrainian authorities only
this will offer the best guarantee for
the protection and safety of nuclear
power plants in Ukraine
Russia's military has no business in
Ukraine's power plants Russian military
have no business in Ukraine
this is why we reiterate our call in
Russia to put an end to the war with
Roy's troops from the international
organized borders of Ukraine and start
sincere talks for a peaceful solution
any initiative to reaching a just and
sustainable piece must be in full
respect of international law the U.N
Charter and the resolutions adopted by
the general assembly
colleagues we don't need to wait and
hope for the diocese to roll and bring
luck we need to ask insist work and
expect for Russia to become to come to
reason and I thank you
Mercier
thank you
Mr President let me start by
congratulating Switzerland for an
impeccable presidency of this organ
during the month of May
I would like also to underline the
excellent cooperation between the
delegations of Brazil and Switzerland
during this period when we have
coincided as elected members of the
security Council
allow me also to thank director General
Grossi for his detailed and very
important briefing
Brazil is a strong supporter of the iaea
we have been especially appreciative of
the agency's recent efforts to enhance
transparency and trust and to ensure the
safe and secure and secure operation of
nuclear facilities in challenging those
years
we believe the agency has played and
should continue to play a key role in
ensuring the Safety and Security of
nuclear facilities in a way that is
depoliticized and open to dialogue with
all stakeholders
as director General Grassi has said in
this Council on previous occasions
nuclear accidents do not recognize
borders
we are encouraged by the fact that the
iaea has been able to keep a permanent
Presence at Zappo region nuclear power
plant providing both technical support
for operations through its experts as
well as timely updates on the plans
functioning through its public facing
Communications
we strongly support i a i a e A's Seven
Pillars of nuclear Safety and Security
in armed conflict and we welcome reports
that the plant continues to have
sufficient staff for the safe operation
of the plant
we nevertheless
are concerned by the reiterated
disruptions to the plant's only existing
is external power line which was
temporarily disconnected last week for
the seventh time
each of these disruptions raises the
risk of a nuclear accident
this repeated redescriptions through
plant operations also make this system
less safe
upholding the Seven Pillars requires
preserving secure off-site power at all
times
Brazil welcomes The Proposal presented
today by the director General on the
five principles for addressing the
situation in this app original Power
Plant
these principles represent an adequate
solution for the political pitfalls that
have thus far prevented full
implementation of the Seven Pillars of
nuclear Safety and Security in the plant
we call on both parties so the conflicts
to individually confirm to the eye
iaea their intention to adhere to those
principles
which represents the best way to avoid
the nuclear catastrophe and to a
complete cessation of hostilities can be
achieved
we hope that future reports by the DJ on
the situation in Japanese power plant we
include information on the
implementation of the five principles
because you cannot stress enough how
critical is the importance of safe and
Security nuclear facilities
Mr President the Brazilian Argentine
agents for accounting and control of
nuclear materials
abacc is a success story with potential
lessons
as recognized by the U.N resolution
76-52 adopted by consensus in December
2021 the agency has been an effective
bilateral confidence building mechanism
with positive effects for peace and
security at sobre at sub-regional and
Regional levels
we are fully aware that we cannot draw a
direct parallel to the current situation
in Ukraine and that of objectives of
abacc
and are not related to safety and
nuclear facilities nevertheless that
experience in our region May Inspire us
to think on how to explore cooperation
on technical issues as an effective
confidence building measure
cooperation at a technical level can
infect their driver for dialogue in
other areas contributing to a positive
cycle as Brazil and Argentine and
Argentina have now sustained for over
three decades
we hope to tap on that experience and on
the contribution of regional mechanisms
for cooperation and peace and security
during our presidency in October
Mr President despite the Divergent
perspectives on how the conflict in
Ukraine should be resolved there is a
consensus on the need to prevent a
nuclear disaster to take place in
zapology
a radius of protection of the plant must
be insured and this should be seen as an
opportunity to establish confidence
building measures among all the
different parties involved
the agency and other partners could help
facilitate this process
but it requires political view from all
elect from All actors directly involved
and I thank you
of China
um
at present the crisis in Ukraine is
still dragging on the situation is still
serious China has always been on the
side of peace
and insists on promoting peace talks in
a political setup we look forward to and
support the resumption of peace talks
between Russia and Ukraine
this requires the joint efforts of the
internet
to create conditions
by starting with themselves
security of your crisis
repeatedly stated its position in
previous Security Council delivery and
on February 24th this year China's
position on the political settlement of
the crisis in Ukraine
which uh specifically caused nuclear
power plants safe and opposes armed
attacks against nuclear power plants
despite repeated warnings and appeals
from the international commutions
several times and related facilities
and the military risks in the area have
continued unabated China is concerned is
deeply concerned about this
every effort to avoid any accident
tuition
of dialogue and the proper solution of
the related issues including the Safety
and Security
the country with significant influence
should play a responsible and
constructive role rather than pouring
oil on a fire China will continue to
work to promote and play a constructive
role in advancing a political settlement
of the crisis in Ukraine I thank you Mr
President
representative
this is
I warmly welcome your presence for this
meeting as we once again see convergence
to address the critical concerns of
nuclear Safety and Security arising from
the Russian Federation sustained
aggression against Ukraine I thank
Ecuador and France for their initiative
in calling for today's meeting and also
thank Mr Rafael Grossi the director
general of the international atomic
energy Agency for his briefing which
highlighted efforts to reign in those
actions that undermine the physical and
operational Integrity of this operation
nuclear power plant Europe's largest
nuclear plant
my delegation continues to share in the
concerns expressed in today's briefing
and more fully exposed in the reports of
the iaea expressed in issued in February
this year and in the subsequent
situational reports on Ukraine
Ghana considers it extremely important
for nuclear facilities anywhere to be
operated with the highest standards of
Safety and Security it says in this
context that we fully support the Seven
Pillars of nuclear safety for
the issues relating to the physical
Integrity of the facilities the
functionality of equipment and security
systems the safety and Independence of
operating stuff secure off-site power
supply
uninterrupted logistical Supply chains
and transportation effective radiation
monitoring systems emergency
preparedness and response measures and
reliable Communications with the
regulator and other stakeholders
in the precarious context of the ongoing
violent conflict in Ukraine where the
associated risk to human lives and the
environment are elevated we affirm that
these pillars are important of
themselves and need to be implemented as
a collective to realize the full gamut
of protection that they can afford
Ukraine and the World At Large
we urge the cooperation of the parties
on all necessary measures including the
commitments just outlined by director
General Grossi to ensure nuclear Safety
and Security beginning with the
demarcation of a demilitarized zone in
and around the power plant and its
facilities
all efforts must also be made to restore
the civilian character of the power
plant at the earliest
we encourage continuous monitoring as is
being done between during the vagus
mechanisms of the iaea including the
expert missions to Ukraine and the
establishment of the presence of
technical experts at the facility and
also welcome further engagements with
the security Council on the
implementation of the outline pillars
and commitments
Mr President today's meeting offers an
opportunity to remind ourselves of the
historical ethical and normative
underpinnings of nuclear disarmament and
non-proliferation
and in so doing to collectively renew
our commitment in support of a world
without nuclear weapons we encourage
restraint and rhetoric and actions that
carry the potential to further escalate
and protract the war
our view is that ending the war on
Ukraine is the best way to reduce the
chances of accidental risk and avoid a
catastrophic incident of global
magnitude
Mr President our concerns on the
humanitarian aspects of the war remain
unresolved as we continue to witness the
persistent targeting of Civilian
populated areas contrary to the
stipulations of international
humanitarian law in this month of May
the city of Kiev has experienced more
than 15 episodes of drone and missile
attacks with reported incidents of
Civilian casualties
we are compelled to retreat the
obligations of Warring parties to
respect and uphold the rules of
international law including
International humanitarian law and human
rights laws in the context of today's
discussions we also underline article 56
of additional protocol 1 to the Geneva
Convention which specifically prohibits
attacks against wax or installations
including nuclear electrical generating
facilities if such attacks may cause the
release of dangerous forces and
consequently cause severe laws among
civilian populations
Ghana remains Resolute in the call for
peace in Ukraine and on that basis we
really treat the urgent need for the
cessation of hostilities to curtail the
laws suffering and destruction which
unfortunately has not let up since the
commencement of the war in February last
year we reaffirm our support for
political settlement through the
channels of dialogue and diplomacy and
maintain the viewpoints that all peace
efforts must respect and uphold
international law and the core
principles of the charter of the United
Nations
lastly I reaffirm Ghana's unwavering
commitment to the sovereignty political
Independence and territorial Integrity
of Ukraine and call on the Russian
Federation to end the war by the
immediate and unconditional withdrawal
of his troops from the internationally
recognized borders of Ukraine I thank
you
I thank the representative
of the United Arab Emirates
Mr President
like to thank director General Grassi
for his valuable briefing today
I extend my gratitude
to him and his team
at the iea for their efforts since the
outbreak of the war in Ukraine
the UAE welcomes your ongoing engagement
with all relevant actors to ensure the
safety and security
nuclear
[Music]
power plant
this report follows month of careful
assessment and visits to the site by the
iea
and we appreciate that that technical
approach of the team of experts which
emphasizes nuclear Safety and Security
on the ground we are we urge all
relevant parties to cooperate with the
ie
Mr President the situation surrounding
zaparosia remains alarming
the fact that Chernobyl and Fukushima
have been invoked in this chamber and
elsewhere
shows that the world has not forgotten
how Brave the consequences of nuclear
misstep could be
it is also reminds us that when it comes
to nuclear safety our security is
intertwined
a nuclear accident would have
catastrophic consequences for Ukraine
The Wider region and the world
we remain concerned by disconnections of
the power plant from the Ukrainian
electrical grid
this has resulted in an interruption of
energy supplies that further threatens
the safety and lives of Ukrainian
already living in a severe humanitarian
situation
the escalation is critically important
to guarantee the plan's normal
functioning
and to prevent a nuclear disaster from
becoming an unintended consequence of
this war
ensuring the safety of nuclear
facilities is the utmost importance for
the UAE
we recall the fundamental principles of
international humanitarian law of
necessity proportionality and
distinction and the special protection
that nuclear facilities are afforded
under International material law
this includes under the additional
protocol to the 1949 Geneva conventions
as well as the obligations to take care
to protect the natural environment
against widespread long-term and severe
damage
these obligation must be protected and
respected
in recent weeks we have seen positive
development emerge the Black Sea grain
initiative will continue for another 60
days
these efforts are proof of what can be
achieved when there is political will
the initiative should be taking
seriously
and by opening the door to political
discussions the initiatives potential as
a confidence building measure could lay
the groundwork for further talks
aimed at a resolution to this conflict
as we have said many times before the
secession of hostilities throughout
Ukraine is the only way to guarantee the
prevention of a nuclear miscalculation
we
reiterate our call for de-escalation and
dialogue to bring this conflict to
Peaceful sustainable solution in line
with the UN Charter
I would like to conclude by
congratulating Switzerland
for its outstanding presidency of the
council this month I thank you Mr
President
thank you
for your statement
capacity I also thank you
representative thank you president I
also thank director General Rossi for
his briefing
as we have heard the situation regarding
nuclear Safety and Security in Ukraine
continues to be of great concern
since February 2022 the world has
watched with worry as Russia has
occupied sabrizia Europe's largest
nuclear power plant as part of its
aggression against Ukraine
let us not forget that the root of the
problem is the illegal presence of
Russian military personnel at the site
we stress the fact that without their
presence the situation we are discussing
today would not exist
with this in mind it is deeply
regrettable that military activities in
and around of the facility as a result
of Russia's actions have placed the
nuclear Safety and Security of the
entire continent in jeopardy
as stated by director General Grossi the
situation is becoming increasingly
unpredictable and consequently more
dangerous such risks are completely
unacceptable
while it remains occupied the zaprito
nuclear power plant has been operating
with significantly reduced Staffing
numbers it has been reported that the
Ukrainian staff who are still there or
working in extremely challenging
conditions faced with intimidation
interrogation and even adduction in some
instances
a humanitarian Corridor for the rotation
of the management operation and repair
staff of the power plant is an idea that
should be given serious consideration to
make sure that the station continues to
function in a safe way
we also note that in recent weeks there
have been reports evacuations from the
town of inner ordar which most staff and
their families live this creates further
uncertainty about the Staffing situation
we welcome the presence of iea Staff
deployed to zaparizian other Ukraine
power plants but emphasize that this
does not amount to a solution even in a
shutdown State this operator nuclear
power plant requires adequate
maintenance and other work
president since Russia's illegal
Invasion and occupation of the region
last February this operation nuclear
power plant and its surrounding area
have been exposed to dangerous miniature
activity the power lines are centered to
the operation and maintenance of safety
of the plant have been damaged on number
of occasions
motor deeply regrets that despite
assurances rosatom has not been granted
access to the iaea to the zabrizia
thermal power plant which has provided
backup power for the nuclear power plant
in the past access for the iaea must be
granted urgently
why we welcome the delivery of 200
Portable Power Systems to Ukraine to
compensate for frequent power losses as
well as the agreement reached earlier
this month between the iaea France and
Energon for the delivery of necessary
spare parts for emergency diesel
generators of the South Ukraine nuclear
power plant we also underline the need
for guarantees of uninterrupted Supply
to zaprizia nuclear power plant from the
territory under the control of the
government of Ukraine
president
Malta also welcomes the recent Shin by
consensus of the U.N General Assembly
resolution on the persistent Legacy of
the China disaster
the adoption by consensus of this
resolution is indicative of the
importance placed by the International
Community on nuclear Safety and Security
in Ukraine and the significance of the
serious long-term consequences of
nuclear disasters
the risks currently posed to nuclear
Safety and Security in Ukraine
endangering the entire world are a
direct consequence of Russia's illegal
unjustified and unprovoked war against
Ukraine
once again motorist rates its call on
Russian Federation to immediately seize
its war of aggression and withdraw all
its forces and military equipment from
Ukraine's internationally recognized
borders
we also remain supportive of the iaea's
continued efforts to finding a permanent
solution for the safety and integrity of
the separated nuclear power plant in
this regard Malta welcomes the
principles as outlined today which
constitute an important foundation to
continue to build and guide future
discussions
the return of full legitimate control
over the facility to the competent
Ukraine authorities included the
militarization and the occupation of the
of the
znpp is a first priority
this is a key prerequisite for restoring
not only nuclear Safety and Security but
also respect for international law
we thank the director general for his
Relentless efforts and the experts at
form part of the iaea supports and
assistance mission to this operation for
their valuable work thank you
represents
to the representative of Ukraine
thank you Mr President distinguished
members of the security Council
I also recognize the representative of
Putin's regime in the permanent seat of
the Soviet Union
I would like to thank Direct General
grocer for his briefing
we express our appreciation for
professionalism and commitment
of the iaea missions experts at Zappa
Asia NPP
temporarily and illegally occupied by
Russia
they continue to work on the extreme
precarious conditions
caused by regular Dangerous provocations
by the Russian troops
we praise The Bravery of the Ukrainian
Personnel working in the inhumane
conditions of constant intimidation and
threats of detention and torture by the
Russian military
Russian forces have mined the perimeter
and shelled Zed NPP side
and the adjacent areas
these actions have led to the violation
of the physical Integrity of the power
plant and serious damage to the station
and AIDS facilities
thus posing a direct threat to life and
health of the operating personnel
they're selling seriously undermines the
nuclear safety of the plant and could
and could lead to a nuclear incident or
accident
this is a clear purpose of pillar one of
the IAA director General's seven
indispensable pillars of nuclear Safety
and Security
which envisages the physical Integrity
of nuclear installations
that must be maintained further it is
the reactors fuel pumps or radioactive
waste stores
Russian military activities regularly
leads to the loss of offside power
there were seven emergency cases since
the beginning of the Russian illegal
occupation
when the plant was in blackout running
only on diesel generators
the most recent Lake blackout
okay secured a week ago on May 22nd
after the Russian missile attack
resulted in the disconnection of the
last high voltage transmission line
notably The Improv Skyline that supplied
power for in-house needs of Z NPP
thanks to the work of Ukrainian Power
Engineers the art the operation of the
transmission line was restored at noon
of the same day and that NPP was
reconnected to power from the Ukrainian
power system
Russia continues to actively use the
nuclear plan for military purpose
deploying there about 500 military
personnel and 50 units of heavy weaponry
equipment munition and explosives are
located in the turbine buildings of
units number one two and four of the
plant
the threat of dangerous accident as a
result of these irresponsible and
criminal actions hangs over us
in this regard we support the commitment
of the iaea director General to fix
these inappropriate situations and
restore nuclear Safety and Security at
znpp in line with above mentioned seven
indispensable pillars
we take note of the director General's
principles to help ensure nuclear Safety
and Security at znpp
the they are partially based on seven
indispensable principles that are
applicable to any nuclear facility
throughout the globe
in case of that NPP however due to the
uniqueness of the situation
illegal occupation of the station by
another state
these principles must be complemented
with the demand of full demilitarization
and the occupation of the station
we reiterate that by illegally occupied
occupying znpp and making it an element
of this military strategy Russia has
violated all key International
principles of nuclear Safety and
Security and the vast majority of its
obligations on the international British
one could hardly consider Russia to be a
reliable partner able
to undertaking commitments
for his part the Ukrainian statue
confirms that we have never resulted and
will never resort to any action that
could lead to a nuclear incident in the
Ukrainian Nuclear Power Plant
we realized the catastrophic
consequences of such an incident for
both Ukraine and neighboring states
and that's why our position on the
fundamental principle of ensuring
nuclear Safety and Security of that NPP
remains clear and consistent
to ultimately remove the nucleus threats
stemming from the illegal Russian
Presence at the plant the troops in the
Weaponry must be withdrawn
the station must be deoccupied and
returned under the legitimate full
control of Ukraine
I would like to remind that a clear call
upon Russia
to immediately seize all actions against
and add that NPP in order for the
competent Ukrainian authorities to
regain full control over these facility
is also enshrined in the relevant
resolutions of the IAA Board of
Governors
in this regards the principles to to
ensure nuclear Safety and Security at
that NPP should also include the
following elements
first
withdrawal of troops and all other
Russian Personnel illegally present at
the station
second
guarantees of uninterrupted power supply
to that NPP from the territory under the
control of the government of Ukraine
third
humanitarian Corridor to ensure the
irritation of management operational and
repair Personnel at znpp in order to
maintain the plant in a safe condition
we also deem it necessary to include the
above elements as well as the reference
to the need to fully implement the above
mentioned resolutions of the iaea Board
of Governors regarding the situation in
Ukraine to a new resolution of the Board
of Governors
if such document is proposed for
adoption at its next session
Ukraine consistently adheres to the
approaches to the prevention of a
nuclear accident at that NPP which are
reflected in the UN General Assembly
resolution a slash res slash ES
11-6
principles of the charter of the United
Nations underlying a comprehensive just
and lusting peace in Ukraine
as well as in the peace formula of the
president of Ukraine
I wish to recall that that radiation and
nuclear safety
is the first point of the peace formula
of the president of Ukraine
and it is vitally important to further
consolidate efforts around this
initiative
the implementation of which will ensure
a just and Lasting peace in Ukraine and
prevent the recurrence of similar crimes
in future including a nuclear area I
thank you
merci Le representative
declaration for
his concluding remarks
thank you very much Mr President and I
would like to thank you and
distinguished members of the council as
well as the distinguished representative
ambassador of Ukraine uh for the
important elements they have given us
today they constitute undoubtedly an
expression of support to the work of the
iaea since the beginning of the war we
take note of different nuances
um and particular aspects raised by by
all around this table I think as my
distinguished Brazilian colleague was
saying there may be differences but
there is consensus in this room around
the idea that there should never be a
nuclear accident and for this the work
of the iaea is truly indispensable I
think Mr President today in the midst of
this complex and concerning
circumstances that we have been living
for the last year and a half today is
constitutes a step in the right
direction when it comes to the safety
and the security of the esophageal
nuclear power plant we are encouraged by
the expressions of support to our work
including on the seven indispensable
pillars and the five principles that I
have established today and we commit
ourselves to continue working to
consolidate them and to be even more
effective
in protecting this facility I also
express our Readiness as was
indicated on different interventions to
continue keeping you abreast and
informed about the situation uh
including the implementation of an
observance of the five principles that I
enumerated today all I would say is that
our work continues items is and
continues to be present there we will
continue and reinforce our presence to
avoid what must be avoided at all costs
that on top of the situation that we are
living through this conflict we would
add the unspeakable tragedy of a nuclear
accident that should never happen the
iaea will spare no effort to make sure
that that is not the case thank you very
much Mr President
conclusion
specific and additional information
inscribed on the list of speakers
matters
[Music]
security security
the meeting is adjourned
foreign